our union is showing a unity of purpose
that makes me proud
at the speed of light
the european union has adopted three
waves of heavy sanctions
against russia's financial system
its high-tech industries and its corrupt
elite
and this is the largest sanctions
package in our union's history
we do not take these measures lightly
but we feel we had to act
these sanctions will take a heavy toll
on the russian economy and on the
kremlin
we are disconnecting key russian banks
from the swift network
we also banned the transaction of
russia's central bank the single most
important financial institution in
russia and this paralyzes billions of
foreign reserves turning off the tap on
russia's and putin's war we have to end
this financing office war
and second
we target important sectors of the
russian economy
we are making it impossible for russia
to upgrade its oil refineries
to repair and modernize its air fleet
and to access many important
technologies it needs to build a
prosperous future we've closed our skies
to russian air club aircraft including
the private jets of oligarchs and make
no mistake
we will freeze their other assets as
well be it yachts or fancy cars or
luxury prosperities will freeze that all
together
and thirdly
in another unprecedented step
we're suspending the licenses of the
kremlin's propaganda machine
the state owned russia today and sputnik
and all as their and all of their
subsidiaries will no longer be able to
spread their lies on to justify putin's
war and to divide our union
and these unprecedented actions by the
european union and our partners
in response of an unprecedented
aggression by russia
each one of these steps has been closely
coordinated with our partners and allies
the united states
the united kingdom
canada and norway but also for example
japan south korea and australia
all of these days you see that more than
30 countries representing well over half
of the world's economy
have also announced sanctions and export
controls on russia
and if putin was seeking to divide the
european union to weaken nato and to
break the international community he has
achieved exactly the opposite we are
more united than ever and we will stand
up in this war that is for clear that we
will overcome and we will prevail we are
united and we stay united
honourable members
i am well aware that these sanctions
will come at a cost for our economy too
i know this
and i want to speak honestly to the
people of europe
we have endured two years of pandemic
and we all wished that we could focus on
our economic and social recovery
but i believe
the people of europe understand very
well
that we must stand up against this cruel
aggression
yes protecting our liberty comes at a
price
but this is a defining moment and this
is the cost we are willing to pay
because freedom is priceless honorable
members this is our principle freedom is
priceless
our investments today
will make us more independent tomorrow
and i'm thinking first and foremost
about our energy security
we simply cannot rely so much on a
supplier that explicitly threatens us
and this is why we reached out to other
global suppliers and they responded
norway is stepping up in january we had
the record supply of lng gas we're
building new lng terminals and working
on interconnectors
but in the long run
it is our switch to renewables and
hydrogen that will make us truly
independent
we have to accelerate the green
transition
because every kilowatt hour of
electricity europe generates from solar
wind hydropower or biomass reduces our
dependency on russian gas and other
energy sources
this is a strategic investment
and my honorable members
this is a strategic investment because
on top
less dependency on russian gas and other
fossil fuel sources also means less
money for the kremlin's war chest this
is also a truth
we are resolute
europe can rise up to the challenge
the same is true on defense european
security and defense has evolved more in
the last six days than in the last two
decades
most member states have promised
deliveries of military equipment to
ukraine
germany announced that it will meet the
two percent goal of nato as soon as
possible
and our union for the first time ever
is using the european budget to purchase
and deliver military equipment to a
country that is under attack
500 million euros for the european peace
facility to support ukraine's defense
as a first batch we will now also match
this
by at least 500 million euro from the eu
budget to deal with the humanitarian
consequences of this tragic war
both in the country and for the refugees
honorable members
this is a watershed moment for our union
we cannot take our security and the
protection of people for granted
we have to stand up for it we have to
invest in it we have to carry our fair
share of the responsibility
and this crisis is changing europe
but russia has also reached
a crossroad
the actions of the kremlin are severely
damaging the long-term interests
of russia and its people
more and more russians understand this
as well
they are marching for peace and freedom
and how does the kremlin respond to this
by arresting thousands of them
but ultimately
the longing for peace and freeze and
freedom cannot be silenced
there is another russia besides putin's
tanks and we extend our hand of
friendship to this other russia be
assured they have our support
honorable members
in these days independent ukraine
is facing a darkest hour
at the same time the ukrainian people
are holding up the torch of freedom for
all of us
they are showing immense courage
they are defending their lives
but they are also fighting for universal
values
and they are willing to die for them
president zielenski and the ukrainian
people are a true inspiration
and when we last spoke
he told me again about his people's
dream
to join our union
today the european union and ukraine are
already closer than ever before
there's still a long path ahead
we have to end this war
and we should talk about the next steps
but i am sure
nobody in this hemi cycle can doubt
that a people that stands up so bravely
for our european values belongs in our
european family
and therefore honorable members
i say
long live europe
and long live a free and independent
ukraine
mess vomit slava ukrainian
you